[Laughter]
it's looking directly at the camera too
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we're talking
about who was your greatest inspiration
what for what for whatever
Focus so defensive oh I don't know
because I have a lot of inspiration for
a lot of different things
so it depends what's your name
I so there's this composer named nobuo
umatsu and he's like uh he he's credited
for doing like most of the music for the
final fantasy series from like the very
first one but he I don't think he does
them now or maybe he does little bits
but uh
he also did some of the earliest like
Nintendo games kind of like some of the
chiptune old school ones like rad Racer
and just like stuff in the 80s and I
didn't even know that I was listening to
him for
um a lot of my early time when I first
started getting piano lessons as a kid
and then I was learning like his songs
and then throughout life like I a lot of
his music always stood out to me but I
didn't know that it was the same guy how
did you learn his song like you had a
cool teacher no I just would like listen
to him and like try to like piece them
out because my piano teacher brought
[ __ ] whack [ __ ] me too Beethoven or
like the Spree the Saints cold Marching
In Like Beethoven that was a banger
though the Saints Go Marching that's the
closest thing to like something that was
catchy did you Moonlight Sonata that
[ __ ] though what is that one
I think you still gotta learn those just
so you can I think that's like the how
you learn how to piece music together
just learning a lot of music and I had
to learn all that stuff too but then
when it was off time I wanted to like
figure out those things and then uh so
this dude was never in America like he's
from Japan and then the first time he
had a concert here in America it was
like impossible to get tickets for it's
like at the bowl and everybody's like it
like sold out immediately the people
dress up in Final Fantasy outfits yeah
they did do a lot of that stuff but it
wasn't it wasn't like it didn't look
like like a cosplay con right now but it
was uh is that the bowl he had an
orchestra and all this stuff and uh I
got to go because by chance one of my
really good friends got hired to be in
his Opera chorus wow just as like uh was
he playing an oboe oh the Opera course
and then uh and then yeah he came out
and did all of his music from Final
Fantasy all the stuff he composed for
all the old games fully orchestrated in
Philharmonic and it was like a dream
come true you get chills yeah you cry I
did yeah I actually did yeah I I have a
confession
I I never played Final Fantasy oh that's
okay I have your confession was I don't
have any inspiration
I inspired myself when I look at my baby
pictures but yeah the the reason he's an
inspiration is because if like my
default style of playing is is a [ __ ]
derivative of of his style of composing
it's very like like you could tell like
oh that everything I play if I'm just
autonomously playing by myself you'll if
you know his [ __ ] you'll go oh it sounds
like his [ __ ] not that it's as good but
it's like yeah it's like it's like a
copy of it in a way that's fine that's
like me and drums like oh that's just
some Nick Cannon shitty
do you have a favorite Final Fantasy uh
six six yeah
you know when I was a kid I played Final
Fantasy like [ __ ] one two three and
four with my friend and then for
Halloween one year he wanted to be
[ __ ] Mages he was like let's do red
manges and I kind of just said okay but
I was kind of thought I was kind of
whack and then just before Halloween
like by like nine days before Halloween
I told my mom I was like I don't want to
be a [ __ ] he's just kind of lame and
then my mom asked me to help me get a
Ninja Turtle costume and then I had to
go to my friend's house and tell him
that I was going to be Raphael and not
be a Red Mage that's kind of dumb to all
of you be red Pages why now that doesn't
make sense well it's like everyone being
Raphael yeah it is I think I think he
was gonna be a black mate
oh okay and so we had even gone as far
as like going into the woods and getting
sticks and then painting them red and
black but then I was like this feels so
whack red Mages are kind of whack dude
major Spirit are whack if you're amazing
who plays who picks Mage like when you
have a who gets healer yeah that's
[ __ ] weird that's the weakest one
yeah
it's being a Bard dude but when you're
playing in a squad someone needs to be a
Healer that's true I know but like it's
always like the guy who is like ah [ __ ]
you know whoever's last last Pickens do
you have an inspiration growing up we
were talking about him earlier but
obviously like Bruce Lee was like my guy
he was like Hey dude dude from like four
and on Wow and so I was like
in what probably like Middle School like
everything was Bruce Lee I remember one
year for one fourth to like sixth grade
I was like Bruce Lee like every [ __ ]
year and my parents were like oh Jesus
Christ
again let's be Bruce Lee again which
Bruce Lee though dude [ __ ] all of
them though yellow tracksuit boostly
return to the dragon Bruce Lee bro they
never told you to be something else yeah
they did like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with this kid dude they were like
worried about me were you shirtless oh
yeah dude I'll wear wife beaters all the
time and have I try to keep nunchucks on
my back pants all the time it was
ridiculous like it was just it was
nonsense but um as I got older you know
and I wanted to start fighting and stuff
I really GSP was like a huge inspiration
I love GSP is the man dude he's such a
like martial artist yeah dude you know
and like at the time he was he was just
so the way he talked about
um training and all that stuff just
trying to be a professional in that way
I just really looked up to him a lot he
was he was he was a big reason why I was
like oh I want to start fighting oh cool
you like how he talks like Karma the
Frog yeah yeah I was like man I wish I
was French Canadian
is that what he is yeah my friend was in
a hot tub with him hey is that what my
friend has a picture in a hot hot tub
with him what oh it's because she's a
girl oh oh yeah nice it's easier to get
I heard GSP loves the ladies if you know
what I mean he's single I think he's
I've never seen him with their wife got
a real [ __ ] Hound so did Bruce Lee yeah
yeah yeah so did Mr Braithwaite
I like ladies too but then I like I also
like being committed to one
okay
[Laughter]
that's cute though not me expect that I
respect that smash what's your
inspiration do you have a respiration
Leonardo from [ __ ] Ninja
that really good inspiration it's a good
answer what he was he was such a suck up
to Splinter though well because good
leaders have to be good followers
[Music]
Michelangelo was the funniest one that I
liked a lot
Raphael I was like why do you keep this
negative [ __ ] leave this bit this he's a
hater I hate him yeah Leonardo and
Donatello even though they fought a lot
I like in between the two I'm like
Donatello you're a [ __ ] nerd but I
you're always right
he is the right he's the voice of reason
oh he's [ __ ] right did you guys hear
about well there's a a turtle's comment
called the last Ronin yeah you guys know
what that is oh wait did you I think you
told me before what happens there
they're [ __ ] dead yeah so then what
happened all four of them well no so um
[ __ ] them dead turtles all over there I
told you yeah I told you about they
killed Donatello in a book yeah but this
is different yeah they killed Donatello
too I guess he could die a lot of these
books this is based off of Steve's
fishing trips
it's a true story I'll take it so um
yeah there's there's a book called The
Last Ronin and basically the idea behind
it spoilies right is that all the turtle
brothers are dead except for
Michelangelo who survived and then which
is kind of great because he's like the
least serious one and he has to be the
most serious one and then he has all of
his brothers weapons and like he's like
fighting yeah
it's really crazy it's pretty hardcore
can he just bring it back to life by
grabbing the scepter and going back in
time
yeah well dude there's I haven't read
the book yet I was just looking at some
of the stuff about it and [ __ ] the comic
is pretty gory it looks sick yeah it
looks very dark yeah but the um they
have a really good method of like still
using the brothers where they're like
come to him in spirit form all the time
balls and [ __ ] be like you [ __ ] up and
we're dead and [ __ ] it's pretty [ __ ]
a lot of people don't know the original
Turtles was a little grittier like it
was like definitely it was meant to be
the original Eastman stuff where they
all had like the red um yeah they're all
they're all red yeah all red Mages do
you have a human inspiration
um oh animal based because I knew it was
going to be non-human really he's like
Air Bud
the soccer one not the basketball ones
yeah yeah he's a [ __ ] hack yeah I
think fictional characters and I think
um oh you don't have any like real life
Inspirations Sunny Chiba when I started
having uh real life Inspirations they
weren't really good Inspirations like I
started to really deep diving into uh
woke [ __ ] like in like I wouldn't even
stay at smoke [ __ ] today like in today's
terms but like when you're thinking like
um as a ninth grader and you're reading
like Communist Manifesto and then you're
really getting deeper into
um
anti-capitalist ideas and then you're
you're you start thinking like oh Che
Guevara is pretty sick and so is um Hugo
Chavez and so is uh Malcolm X and so is
and you start reading all these things
and then um they become like oh these
guys are fighting against the big giant
America and then so it's like this
Underdog Story
and communism does a really good job of
creating like good propaganda that young
people can like follow and I think those
things were kind of in my mind at the
time like oh yeah these guys are badass
I want to be like that for some reason
ninth to tenth grade and then those were
my first uh
people that were like oh these guys
fought against they're like David
against Goliath like human being
Inspirations you didn't have just like a
regular one like Tony Hawk is pretty
cool
that's how it started it all started
with like that's kind of a brand with a
joke
what about Michael Jackson my God yeah
no but Michael Jackson I knew they would
be out of this world yeah yeah yeah
Michael Jackson was like I wanted to him
to be my friend like he was my age you
know like when we I don't know if you
guys saw Michael that way but I saw
Michael as like he's like he's like an
adult that's a kid that understands and
he's like a little bit older
that's how I saw him you know what
that's called oh
Michael Jackson's desire
but then I didn't see him as like like
to me I saw him as Robin Williams like
in hook he's like he has an adult's body
but he's like one of us you know so like
when I watch hook and all that but they
weren't like oh when I grow up I want to
be an adult right
do you think that you think Michael
Jackson was like oh he's an adult but
he's like he's like he gets it he's in
kid world he can get it right Neverland
I thought he was tired I never thought
that he could [ __ ] me though or anything
no I never said that
I thought that's what you're saying
sorry he could [ __ ] me so hard as long
as he keeps making that music man those
hitters no I never saw I never saw him
as like oh when I grow up I want to be
like this person
never thought that yeah yeah it doesn't
seem like you're trying to be like
Michael Jackson too much I think it is I
wanted to be like him at the moment but
I think you're a pop culture Sensational
but I don't I don't think I have any
person just even up until College where
I was like this human being is who I
want to be when I become an adult oh I
see
or like qualities that you like or who
you want to be like oh I had people that
were human like around me like one of
them was my Bible teacher he was cool I
had humans around dude I chose the
[ __ ] most roundabout answer this is
like SBF being interviewed
he's looking deflecting everything it's
not a deflection oh yeah no I do
you know quality because he kept
said cartoons and [ __ ]
well like okay so so someone who
inspired me I would say is one of my um
Junior High teachers he's a Bible
teacher Mr Gonzalez he was cool as [ __ ]
dude that was weird dude
that's sick
because I'd say like he was the first he
was the first teacher that broke that
like he's a cool teacher oh it's not
like all about rules it's hard to do
yeah and then and then like people like
you can you come to him and [ __ ] and
you're like well that's a good human
being he cares about the students that's
hard to do yeah and it's it's a topic
like Bible
[Laughter]
so he's just a sick dude
he's a real Chill Bill that looks all
right Anthony weird what about you bud
yeah what kind of Inspirations do you
have that's dude
[Laughter]
tell your story tell your story
it's looking directly at the camera too
it's like the actual person right there
your eyes are too far apart this is Joe
and we have a new guest and they've been
talking for four minutes
um this is a good technique right here
yeah that's why I got it for all Steve
today hey easy
I feel like to answer this question
maybe Daft Punk really you can't even
see them you can't even see me
so like about back in high school or
later on inspired by these two robots I
feel like right at the beginning of
college oh yeah but but I think the uh
the time frame of like falling in love
with them was synonymous to the time
frame of falling in love with dance uh
so I think that's why it's like it holds
such a heavy spot in my heart what's
your favorite song mine was around the
world I love that song I love that song
got to that one too
I think the most uh most like at that
time maybe like harder better faster
stronger was so fun to hear great and
just uh to to dance to and pretend like
I was really really sick Dancer too
um I didn't [ __ ] directing and
dedicating an entire like showcase to
them called Daft Funk head cold shock do
that for like a like a 13 minute set or
some [ __ ] where we just did a bunch of
their songs and medleys
um just [ __ ] love them you know
they're they're Aura their Motif the the
way they just want to bounce up the
reason why they named themselves that
funk was because somebody was talking
[ __ ] on them calling their music Daft
Punk you know so they're like oh we'll
call ourselves Daft Punk
um [ __ ] like that that was kind of a
coin on it what does that mean Daft Punk
is that German or some [ __ ] though no no
no punk no it's British actually I think
right is it isn't it French they are
French or maybe it was a translation but
some somebody calling something Daft is
usually what like you're a Daffy Duck
it's like British people yeah it feels
like British people say it's just like
Daft Punk that's stuffed they're like
it's like weak yeah and then they just
took that and they are they're kind of
in the way that people like you know see
Bruce Lee as the forefather of like MMA
they're like the forefathers of EDM
so like before it got to just like you
know the stereotype idiom it's like they
really were like the ones that brought
electronic dance music to like the scene
right you Bert
uh when I was a kid for sure Bruce Lee
no I said that you got a picture
you can't pick mine say Tony Hawk dude
but it was for real Bruce Lee because
kung fu is like Chinese skateboarding
and then like I was literally yeah I
would practice that [ __ ] in the backyard
like I loved it I practiced my Sidekicks
yeah and I'm like oh man I gotta [ __ ]
turn the toe down and [ __ ] did you read
his books [ __ ] practice but he's not
as good as Ninja Turtles no they were
way better more flips I would actually
read his books even though I was Dumb
and I don't know how to read I'll
pretend like I'm reading
type of Rhythm and then my parents were
divorced so like when I would go to my
stay at my dad's house the thing he
would do is we'd go to the Chinese like
video store and we would just rent a
stack of [ __ ] movies so like Jet Li's
in there Donnie yam uh Bruce Lee of
course and then I think from one of my
birthdays I got a Chinese connection or
like Mr Fury and I would just watch that
thing on repeat over and over and over
and over
and then when I got a little bit older I
would say
um changes no I think maybe like in
junior high I think probably Tupac
I just loved how like he just spoke his
mind
I was like like maybe because I grew up
as a [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat man yeah I
grew up like in a very Asian like oh you
gotta think of it you gotta stay like
this is an origami in your house or
whatever and then like I just like that
I just liked how I was just like [ __ ]
you and he would just say crazy [ __ ] to
the like [ __ ] the D.A or whatever I'll
go oh this guy's very expressive like
I'm so impressive
and then when I got into music
oh man
um I would say freshman sophomore years
when I really got into music Beethoven
that was a good no hell no
it's a that's a good one
Beethoven uh one of the guys is his
name's uh Chad here we go no not Chad
Sexton who's Chad Hugo from the Neptunes
oh I don't know
yeah [ __ ] I forgot if it was Chad Sexton
or Adrian young
um but he played drums for No Doubt oh
is it the Indian dude no no that has a
basement but I thought it was really
tight that um I think Chad sex does 311
and Adrian young is uh no doubt but I I
thought it was dope that he was just
self-taught and he just auditioned for a
band and he got in and then he musically
like upped his level to be where the
band was at and I just thought that was
fun that's cool that was really really
cool
um because I felt like I was like
classically trained as a percussionist
and I wasn't as good as this guy that
was just I'm about it and I'm gonna just
learn learn that stuff and then when I
got into like comedy with Joe for sure
Dave Chappelle I just loved his like
storytelling and just yeah for sure one
and like his his jokes are like hits you
in the in the soul he's so good yeah
it's almost like Soul comedy
and that's it I think
no fictional characters in yours yeah
Master Splinter was pretty sick though
he was he was pretty gangster dude yeah
he's too old I couldn't believe it maybe
Captain Planet because he cares about
Mother Nature
in my school you got your ass beat for
liking Captain Planet
that was like when you had when you had
really controlling parents and they
didn't want you to watch [ __ ] content
they made you watch that though my best
Halloween costume of all time was
Captain Planet with the green wig I
swear I was walking down Hollywood
Highland I got the most compliments I've
ever gone to any other costume a Captain
Planet muscle suit with the [ __ ]
group yeah that's just gangster I loved
it wow do you pay your face silver do
you paint your face silver nah dude
that's racist yeah you're right good
call but there was one useless one the
useless one in there was the one that
goes hard oh yeah oh yeah you mean the
most important one Joe that is the most
important
you got no [ __ ] that guy he's a
necklace wearing little [ __ ] what was
his power like yeah but what would he do
though it makes people have the
compassion necessarily Save the Planet
if you watch it back he was mostly
driving the van and [ __ ] he was there a
personal assistant you would get him
coffee before he was formatting the cars
making sandwiches he wasn't doing
anything all I remember is there's an
episode where they're all like they go
to like the dystopian future and they
all still have their rings but like the
planet's [ __ ] and then um he's like
he's like broke and he has like a mug
the heart kid and then a [ __ ] Guy
Walks Behind he goes heart and the guy
goes puts a coin in his cup
and that's all he could do yeah he made
people feel compassionate yeah that's
tight and that guy's like damn I really
needed that coin
I can't buy bread though [ __ ] would I do
that that's the only thing I remember
heart doing do that oh my wife's gonna
kill me we're gonna tell her yeah Steve
agreeing what about you uh Limp Biscuit
which which Grand wizard
which Grand wizard
is he still performing
I don't know is it about the is that all
about that he said she said though oh
[ __ ]
uh no for me it's Bill Murray I think
I've said that yeah you killed me yeah
oh [ __ ] that's funny I watched
Ghostbusters like non-stop as a child
and like you know I would always my
parents said I watched that movie for
like five years straight he's so funny
that guy I smell all the drummers of all
the bands really yeah from the biscuit
the drum is John Otto I was super into
drums so that was your thing huh yeah
for a while yeah and then I found drugs
and [ __ ] that's like how for some reason
I remember all the capitals of South
American countries I don't know
Bogota Colombia Quito Ecuador Lima Peru
it was a song yeah I think that's what
it was oh yeah why do I know that too
[Music]
[Music]